the u.s says it decided to close its
embassy in kiev due to russia's military
escalation on the ukrainian border
an invasion as we have said
could begin at any time
should putin decide to order it there
would be widespread human suffering
americans in ukraine have been told to
leave the country but a core group of
u.s diplomats will remain they'll work
from the city of louisville further west
from the border with russia
despite the embassy's closure the white
house says it remains actively engaged
in finding a diplomatic solution to the
crisis the path for diplomacy remains
available if russia chooses to engage
constructively
however we are clear-eyed about the
prospects of that given
the steps russia is taking on the ground
in plain sight
president biden says he will not send
u.s troops to defend ukraine in the
event of an invasion but american
soldiers are standing by across the
border in poland a member of the nato
alliance real lives will be at risk
ukrainian lives to be sure
but also russian lives
this
this will not be bloodless
this will not be easy
a pentagon spokesman says the u.s has
not concluded that russia's president
has decided to invade ukraine but that
an invasion could come with little or no
warning president biden spoke with the
uk's prime minister and discussed
reinforcing nato's eastern defenses and
the u.s defense secretary is now headed
to belgium where he will meet with
military allies heidi joe castro al
jazeera washington